it's causing serious friction between
the united kingdom and the european
union as well as some serious supply
line issues but what is the northern
ireland protocol and why does it matter
the northern ireland protocol was
negotiated between the uk and the eu as
part of the brexit withdrawal agreement
it essentially governs trade across the
irish sea
as part of the protocol northern ireland
remains part of the uk's customs
territory but it also has to stick to
some eu rules so that goods can move
freely into the republic of ireland and
onto the rest of the eu
when ireland and northern ireland were
both in the eu they shared the same
trade rule so there was no need for any
sort of rigorous checks on goods
traveling between them but then brexit
happens and a new agreement was needed
and suddenly it became the main log jam
during the brexit negotiations
all sides agreed that protecting the
good friday agreement was an absolute
priority that meant keeping the land
border between northern ireland and the
republic of ireland open and avoiding a
hard border
the issue here is that the republic of
ireland and northern ireland did once
have a hard border which came about as a
result of the troubles which saw
communities separated and violence
between opposing groups for almost 30
years
remember boris johnson describing the
protocol as a good arrangement and
promising there be no checks on trade
between britain and northern ireland
well that hasn't happened instead
there's been delays with goods like
medicines arriving from britain and
problems with pets on the movement of
live animals on seeds and plants as well
as occasionally some pretty sparse
supermarket shelves
the protocol is not working
it's completely lost consent in one
community in northern ireland it's not
doing the thing it was set up to do now
the europeans have proposed a raft of
measures to ease those issues cutting
checks they say by up to 80
but bars johnson and his team say the eu
has to totally amend the protocol and
they want to scrap the role of the
european court of justice as a sort of
referee for disputes we need to be able
to just pick up the phone order the
produce in the uk and let it arrive here
the way it used to all of this means
that britain is now threatening to
trigger article 16. that's basically
something to be used in the worst case
scenario where the protocol is deemed to
be causing economic societal or
environmental difficulties liable to
persist or to the diversion of trade it
means that either the eu or the uk can
then suspend parts of the withdrawal
agreement but it is being seen very much
as an option of last resort and it's not
on the table for the moment
so can either side throw a lifeline to
the beleaguered protocol it's the time
once again for intense talks and
negotiations between britain and the eu
to see if they can tweak it so it works
for both sides
if things go badly that could lead to
the uk triggering article 16 but that
could also lead to retaliation by the eu
potentially including new tariffs on
british imports and a potential trade
war
realistically both sides will be doing
everything they can to try and avoid
that nightmare scenario after all we've
already had a sausage war out of the
protocol let's hope it's not a taste of
things to come